professional wrestling literally the
only good excuse to wear a onesie and
that's right babies you're not pulling
it off put on some jeans and a
button-down like a person
specifically I want to talk about the
undisputed corporate champion of
wrestling the WWE formerly known as the
WWF until and this is true they lost a
court case to the World Wildlife Fund
presumably thanks to that funds powerful
team of Panda lawyers and look before we
go any further let me say this I like
wrestling and you might be surprised to
hear that but I don't you it's
objectively entertaining and the WWE has
over the years delivered numerous
ludicrous and genuinely incredible
moments from when jake the snake'
roberts set a live Cobra on Macho Man
Randy Savage did the time braun strowman
suplex the big show off the turnbuckle
and broke the entire ring to end Stone
Cold Steve Austin drove a beer truck
into the arena and sprayed the
corporation with a beer hose not to be
mistaken with it on that Kurt Angle
drove a milk truck into the arena and
sprayed Stone Cold Steve Austin with a
milk hose and then there was whatever
the this is
[Applause]
everything about that is fantastic but
my favorite part is after the table was
lit on fire the commentator asking
what's gonna happen what was he
expecting to happen Oh
the tables on fire oh my god here comes
a hibachi chef and he's making one of
those on the table it is were talking
about the WWE tonight for multiple
reasons first it's astonishingly popular
it has over a billion fans on social
media it has two highly rated cable
shows its own streaming network reality
shows video games and even a movie
studio which has produced such hits as
the Scorpion King walking tall the
Marine the Marine - the Marine 3 the
rooting for the marine 5 the marine 6
and of course Lincoln by the way by the
way their first choice to play Abraham
Lincoln was actually Brutus the barber
beefcake but he wasn't available so the
role went to Daniel day-lewis who was he
was he was fine I'm not this company
makes a lot of money last year it
generated a record 930 million in
revenue in fact WrestleMania alone which
is taking place next Sunday is one of
the most valuable sports brands in the
world ranking higher than the World
Series which actually makes sense when
you think about it because while the
World Series is mostly spent watching a
millionaire in a button-down think about
whether or not to throw a ball
WrestleMania involves things like this
[Applause]
are you not going to change how could
any other TV show top that in fact every
other show she just because
unfortunately not a guy exploding
through her table and this show should
very much be included in that but but
the other reason that it's worth talking
about the WWE's because of the
prevalence of stories like these Eddie
Guerrero found dead in a Minneapolis
hotel room the World Wrestling star was
just 38 years old we have just confirmed
that Randy Macho Man Savage has died
Chyna
one of the most famous wrestlers in the
90s has now died she was 46 years old
pro wrestling legend King Kong Bundy has
died at the age of 61 he came here we
were in studio a and he relayed me
almost up to the ceiling he'll be missed
just 61 years old these wrestlers died
in early wow that is a harrowing
statement there from Brian Kilmeade
only slightly dampened by his childlike
wonder and how high the big man lifted
him and how did that even happen did
Bundy offer him did kill me to ask
honestly I wouldn't really be surprised
if one of his stock interview questions
is up horsey rides but Kilmeade is not
actually wrong there because Redfoo
flying early is a troubling trend 538
tracked the rate of deaths among WWF
wrestlers and the findings were
startling
here is the expected death rate by age
group among the population as a whole
here is the rate among former NFL
players and here is the rate among
wrestlers that is shockingly high you'd
expect that line to be labeled test
pilots who lied on their resume or
zookeepers who aren't just gonna let
some baboon screen to them like
that
hey hey enough sass-mouth there buddy
put some respect on my name so so with
that in mind tonight
a week ahead of Wrestlemania let's take
a look at how the WWE does business and
how it treats its wrestlers and before
we start you can't talk about the WWE
without talking about its chairman and
CEO Vince McMahon because he's
incredibly powerful as you can see in
this actual photo he took for a fitness
magazine the magazine scary grandpa who
looks like a big bumpy hot dog Horton
Vince bought the company from his dad
and has since overseen its meteoric
ascent into the mainstream because
before he came along wrestling was
splintered into fiefdom around the
country all of which had their own
broadcasts welcome to this special
edition of world class Championship
Wrestling welcome this week's edition of
mid-south wrestling welcome to video
manic Championship Wrestling I get
wrestling is all about spectacle and
pageantry but a tuxedo gym a tuxedo tone
it down a notch you're not at a
gala
Michael as usual no notes you look great
to keep living your truth throughout the
80s and 90s Vince McMahon gradually
eliminated or absorbed his competitors
and now one giant company basically
holds a monopoly on the industry and
it's impossible to overstate just how
involved Vince is he's not just CEO he
obviously storylines scripts everything
even playing a fictionalized version of
himself as the show's over arching
villain although his choices of how to
dramatize that have been pretty
questionable whether it's him forcing
female wrestlers to strip or beating up
his supposed illegitimate son
Hornswoggle or dropping the ultimate
racial slur as part of a comedic skits
yeah what's good
that is rough to watch and remember he's
in complete control of those scripts no
one is making him do that and well yes
he is playing a villain there there are
many other ways that that can be
achieved Darth Vader was a great villain
not once did he drop the n-word
meanwhile r2 said it pretty much
non-stop it's why he kept getting bleep
but but but the fact that that man is an
active character in wrestling actually
gives us an opportunity because he's
taken a lot of in ring abuse over the
years so I point tonight where you're
gonna be disgusted with him for say
using the n-word I can now simply play a
clip like this of the rock smashing them
over the head with a trash can lid
[Applause]
wrestling's good it's just very good but
while the character Vince is an
it's important to know that the real
Vince is also an and many fans
legitimately hate him because well the
WWE has made him a billionaire many
wrestlers say he's treated them terribly
just listen to Bret hitman Hart weren't
one of the biggest wrestlers of all time
speaking about his former boss Vince
McMahon has always had this mentality
about treating wrestlers like circus
animals all these wrestlers that have
broke their backs making this living for
years end up with nothing when it's over
and then they sort of take you out back
and they put a slug in the back of head
and dump you out now that's the life of
a professional wrestler now that might
sound extreme to you but Hart has good
reason to be angry his own brother Owen
died wrestling for Vince and Hart is
frankly far from a lung in voicing
grievances about his former employer
because the shocking thing about McMahon
in his company is the extent to which he
shielded himself from responsibility for
his wrestlers welfare and the main way
that he's done this is actually pretty
simple because well you might reasonably
think that the wrestlers employed by him
are his employees they're actually not
that they're merely independent
contractors just as former wrestler
Jesse Ventura pointed out on Howard
Stern it's just insane power they self
employed when you're signed exclusively
right you can't work for nobody else a
monopoly yeah they tell you when and
where you'll work they tell you who you
work they can totally control your life
and you and yet anaconda and yet they
call you an independent contractor how
has the government allowed them to get
away with that for 35 to 40 years yeah
he's got a point there an independent
contractor is someone that you might
hire for a specific limited task like a
plumber or an accountant wrestlers
aren't either of those things apart from
this wrestling plumber and this
wrestling accountant but the vast
majority are totally different and as
independent contractors wrestlers are
exempt from most discrimination and
occupational safety laws they also don't
get paid annual leave pensions or health
insurance and I would argue that when
you look at the Department of Labor and
the IRS is specific criteria for
independent contractors it's a complete
joke to think that they apply to Vince's
wrestlers for instance the IRS states
that independent contractors should be
free to work when and for whom they
choose well
Vince's wrestlers sign exclusive
contracts so that's complete
the guidelines also say that someone's
probably not an independent contractor
if the success or continuation of a
business depends to an appreciable
degree on the services they provide now
I guess the question there is our
wrestlers essential to World Wrestling
Entertainment it's a good question I
mean it's not called world totally empty
ring entertainment so that might be a
clue in fact if I might quote the
company's own website WWE performers of
the company's greatest asset without our
performers WWE would not exist
and look maybe when wrestlers might work
years ago for multiple different
organizations it made sense to call them
contractors but now that WWE has a
chokehold on this industry it makes just
as much sense to call them that as it
does to call Jimmy Carter a
panty-dropping machine it's just
clearly not true anymore
look for what it's worth
back in 1986 Ventura actually tried to
unionize wrestlers which could have
dramatically improved their working
conditions but man stamped it out heart
and if that makes you want to see
someone stamp him out hard I actually
have some good news for you
[Applause]
wrestling is better than the things you
like and the lack the lack of a union to
advocate for wrestlers means that Vince
gets to call all the shots because while
literally every major sports league has
an offseason for athletes to recover the
WWE works its wrestlers year-round
multiple times a week both on TV and in
untelevised so-called house shows and
big stars may be able to command big
money for that but not every wrestler is
a big star and whenever we've gotten
glimpses of wrestlers contracts they
contain some astonishing clauses one
says if a wrestler is unable to wrestle
for as little as six weeks because of an
injury the company can terminate their
contract
well another releases the company from
all liability for damage resulting in
permanent injury or death even if caused
by its own negligence which is a crazy
thing for McMahon to put in a contract
and frankly enough to make you want to
see him be on the receiving end of his
own medical mishap still technically
more helpful than a visit from dr. oz
when you take all of this together with
wrestlers working as independent
contractors in a monopolized industry
largely free from meaningful oversight
and able to be fired at any time you
wind up with an environment with huge
potential for unsafe conduct before
Lance mcnaught died at 29 of heart
failure while struggling with addiction
to painkillers he spoke of the pressure
that he felt to work through injury
saying everybody knows that if you get
hurt you work through it because you'll
lose your spot and another top wrestler
CM Punk has questioned the advice that
he was given by a WWE doctor following
an incident in the ring I got hit with
something and it rung my bell
and I got a concussion but we were
leaving for Europe the next day so doc
was leaning on me going do you want me
to do you have a concussion or can you
go to Europe kind of thing and I was
just like you you pigs I'll go
to Europe whatever that's on me that's
my fault I'm dry heaving after every
match I'm either puking for real or I'm
just dry heaving because I don't have
anything in my stomach that's like oh
you're sick here's a z-pack they z-pak
me to death so much then too
whereas my pants on a Smackdown he
did he actually did that and we actually
found that episode of SmackDown
smackdown and out of common courtesy we
are not going to show it to you but this
is his face as it was happening Punk
even tweeting about it afterwards saying
just my britches on Smackdown
please retweet something good WWE then
made him take down even though it's
obviously the best tweet ever written
seriously you try and think of a better
suite right now have you got one does it
say mark britches please retweet
then it's not better is it stand down
look obviously gets much worse
thanking past wrestlers
themselves on live TV
because wrestlers bodies regularly get
smashed up and undergo general wear and
tear damage that's cumulative and can
last a lifetime but McMahon doesn't
provide health insurance for his
wrestlers for anything other than
injuries that occur inside the ring in
fact the extent to which he's denied any
responsibility for their welfare is
astonishing just watching respond to a
question years ago about wrestler deaths
do you have a reason why these people
would be dying under the age of 45 why
don't you ask yourself that question I
mean why why what are you indicating
that's my responsibility these people
are dead because asking you if it's in
any way shape or form falls on your
shoulders
I would accept no responsibility
whatsoever for their untimely deaths
none whatsoever
as far as and you've got that look on
your face like yeah well but none
whatsoever I mean they wrestled for you
it was the heart of your organization
they had worked a couple of hundred
nights a year for you they live this
lifestyle what are you doing
you weird weird man and while all of
that is ridiculous my favorite response
isn't actually the weird face or the
smacking of the papers it's answering
why our wrestlers dying early with why
don't you ask yourself that question
which in terms of dodges is certifiably
insane I don't know things maybe because
that journalist doesn't employ any
wrestlers I want to know that you don't
think you do either I'm telling you
you're wrong about that
now the company will say that they've
completely transformed in recent years
and they have taken some positive steps
like banning Church shots in their head
and introducing concussion protocols
although CM Punk's experience probably
suggests that there may be room for some
significant improvement there but but
some of the other steps they've taken
under their talent wellness program are
a little underwhelming like the fact
that they now have annual physical
examinations that's just nothing I have
to take one of those every year to host
this show and I've never once exploded
through this table it's in the name of
our show now the program also provides
for things like cardiovascular and brain
testing which is nice although remember
they're still responsible for their own
health insurance and while the company
says it pays for addiction treatment for
former wrestlers that doesn't really
address the underlying issues that get
them hooked on pain medication in the
first place and the tragic thing is some
have reluctantly had to drag their
bodies back to the WWE because they have
no other financial option rowdy roddy
piper continued wrestling into his 40s
and 50s and just listen to him explain
why wrestling is it has a tremendous
entrance plan you come in as boy here
you are you rock the wall and everything
is one it's got no exit plan and rowdy
roddy piper should know a few months ago
he climbed back into the ring what would
you have me do it 49 when like my
pension plan I can't take out till I'm
65 I'm not gonna make 65 let's just face
facts guys and sadly he was right about
that cuz Roddy Piper died in 2015 at the
age of 61 and while nothing I say can or
should make that okay I do hope they're
watching this final clip events in the
ring gives you just a tiny piece of
catharsis
[Applause]
you know the reassuring thing there is
you can fake being kicked in the face or
hit in the head with a bedpan but there
is no faking that so I guess the
question is is there any pulp here but
incredibly there might be because there
is one group that even McMahon
occasionally seems to listen to and
that's the fans they actually have a
strong independent voice in the WWE and
have been vocal over the years about
everything from the company's dealings
with Saudi Arabia to its treatment of
female wrestlers who have come a long
way from the old days of so-called bra
and panty matches in fact fans online
launched their hashtag give divas a
chance campaign at a feature women more
more prominently to which Vince himself
responded we hear you keep watching and
next week for the first time ever
Wrestlemania will be headlined by a
women's match so wrestling fans don't
just go along with whatever the company
tells them to cheer and boo they know
what they like and just as importantly
what they don't like
for instance the WWE tried for years
literally years to make Roman reigns a
superstar hero on the level of the rock
but fans just didn't like him and they
let him and the WWE know about that and
keep in mind as he watch this Roman
reigns is supposed to be a good guy
[Applause]
they boot him non-stop for eight minutes
and you might think that's harsh but I
know he was the only rational response
to someone with permanently wet hair how
could it always be wet you look like a
pedophile out for a jog boo boo so so
the fans have a big voice here that's
the point and they really care about
these wrestlers and continue to do that
long after the WWE has abandoned them
and nowhere was the extent of this
devotion more obvious than when
legendary wrestler jake the snake'
needed help paying for medical expenses
Jake had is no insurance he didn't have
any money to pay for the surgery so we
had to come up with some kind of
solution so we we put up a page on
IndieGoGo to try to raise the money for
a surgery I'm real but the really
cool thing that came out of that was
Jake got to see how much the fans really
cared all those years ago say I guess
they did leave something yeah
those years meant a lot of fans that's
why they want him and other wrestlers to
be taken care of they've actually been
multiple GoFundMe campaigns to cover
both healthcare and funeral expenses for
wrestlers that fans have stepped up for
which is heartwarming but frankly fans
shouldn't be the ones shouldering that
responsibility here's how bad it is even
the NFL for all its massive thoughts now
offers players health reimbursement
accounts and have established a legacy
fund for older players who may be
dealing with health issues and when
you've lost the moral high ground to the
NFL you are lauralee subterranea
the potential opportunities because
remember WrestleMania the biggest event
in the WWE's calendar is next Sunday any
fans in that arena
what McMahon to help pay for wrestlers
long term health care or just to call
them employees they could say choose to
make up a chance about that the event is
live
the crowd is miked they won't be able to
cut the chance out I'm not saying that
fans should do that or make signs or
make lots of signs I'm just saying I
really hope they make their voices heard
on this because given that business Hulk
here is a billionaire on the broken
backs of his non employees the very
least he can do is show the same
dedication to wrestlers that they have
shown to his company on I know that I
haven't really said any of this tonight
in the preferred language of wrestling
fans so maybe this will help
wrestling fans cheered Royal Rumble real
the Hell in a Cell
you killed your head off at SummerSlam
ready to scream for something new I'm
talking about Louds or favorite
wrestlers having access to retirement
care workers comp and family and
vertical
[Applause]
walking comfortably bending their knees
past a 90-degree angle a spending
quality time with their grandchildren
you can see all this is more the system
was put in place that gave wrestlers
things like an offseason because the
human body was not designed to do things
like this 200 nights a year we're
talking about bringing three mature
wrestlers they're back in line with
actuarial tables he's gonna need a
doctor
they preferably one who won't make it
advance on Smackdown
before it is at WrestleMania 35 why not
join thousands of screaming fans and
calling for your favorite wrestlers to
be employee though you never have to pay
for their future surgery drew go mr.
McMahon doesn't like it you know what he
can do
[Applause]
the decision